[Musik]
Einkaufen
sind seit langem Bewohner des südwestlichen historischen
alte russische Länder nannten sich
Russisch und orthodox
Katzen und
[Musik]
dann stehen 12 kilometer glasleisten bei bm
Paschki und die Shawnee Rublik sind
es ist kein klarer ruhm für die ukraine
alles ist klar anders sag hallo
das Wort Lichtung zu
sondern
dann Betreiber
unserer Kameraden, Verwandte, unter denen es keine gibt
nur kollegen freunde ehemalige kollegen
aber auch verwandte leute sind vom navi aus verbunden
blutsverwandtschaft
Gut gemacht, wir schleifen genau das und
wollte auf dich warten
Russische Nafs in unserem Keller gefangen
Hof mit Maschinengewehren mit all dem Militär
Timurov-Pfannkuchen
wie geht es ihr so ​​schlecht
ukrainische Paare können
ging für einen rauschenden Straßenbahnprofi und Geschmack
Fjodorow
Ich möchte auch die höchste Bewertung abgeben
Aktionen russischer Soldaten und Offiziere
sie handeln mutig
beruflich
heldenhaft
brechen Jungs brechen zusammen
Sie können nach Russland und Sie zurückziehen
essen, wohin du gehst
Ihre Einheitsaufgabe
Sie trafen in dieser Zeit Vorfahren
Bieger
[Musik]
froh über die ukraine
wofür
bestanden
Du denkst, ich lehne aus Spaß ab 5
reibungslos mitlaufen kann und beschlossen hat, nicht zu warten
während 6 brut, wenn sie am Vortag [ __ ]
Ich werde ihn beschützen, bis
und der Panzer ist überwältigt, ja, das ist die Rose von Russland
sokolov für ein paar
Kinder werden sich im Haushalt als nützlich erweisen
[Musik]
für Jersey uns, bis sie van und will
hier ist martynyuk
wie ein verängstigter Mückenballen a
drei Tanks und und und
also Hautmousse oder Leute, ihr seid Weißrussen
dass sie wegen Gift nach Hause kommen könnten
Wer ist Ukrainer, schlage ich Ihnen vor
legen unsere verdammten Waffen nieder, bis wir
Kommen Sie, treffen Sie sich und Lobby
das heißt, ich lebe hier
Oh
[Musik]
Hier ist ein Geruch
Wahrscheinlicher ist, dass Shusha zurückkehrt
Marina schlecht an
Gänseregen gehen rückwärts
hände eng ramadan und lassen ihren platz
Hose
von Leuten